I'm going to show you an interview of
former Trump propaganda Steve Bannon
interviewing a crazy person now I don't
say that lightly okay uh one of the
things in this clip that I'm going to
show you this this is Bonker stuff I
wouldn't let children see this it's so
disturbing uh Steve Bannon interviews
a woman named Mary Beth
is that her first name is that her first
and middle name is that her first and
last name we have no idea her name is
Mary Beth supposedly and Mary Beth says
she believes that the satanic temple is
secretly sending recruiters to school in
after school programs to recruit and
even grab children
think about that for a second and Steve
Bannon
I guess kind of pretends like Mary Beth
is a sane person and one of the what's
the point here mental health very
serious issue not to be stigmatized we
want everybody to have access to Mental
Health Services it's not a joke or any
of it okay the point here is
much of what the right has normalized as
political discourse
is the sort of stuff that really should
be handled by mental health
professionals let's listen if it isn't
in your school system it will be soon so
please be on the lookout for it
um like I said it kind of snuck up on us
we had no idea I've told people about it
they think I'm crazy when I talk about
it yeah but Google it look for it and
definitely look for it in your school
system I would go to an after-school
program or you're one of the parents
have to work and they've got to stay
after school one of the things in these
in the satanic people are are wandering
around the school hall because trust me
they'll be looking for they'll be
looking to grab these kids and put them
in there
so that's very concerning to me
um yeah the satanic temple has
infiltrated after school programs this
is crazy stuff
and the fact that Steve Bannon has her
on and sort of pretends like this is a
real concern this is that this is a
normal thing
fuels a crisis in this country and I
want to what's it's so difficult to
address this topic
we don't I don't want to be
disrespectful nor minimize mental
illness
we also have to be clear that there are
certain things that it's not just the
difference of opinion it's not it's it's
it's something much more pernicious and
more than that and we have to be able to
say these people have lost connection
with reality we're not diagnosing any
particular person but there are paranoid
delusions that are really really common
here let me give you an analogous
situation which is actually quite sad
a lot of people from different walks of
life watch the David Pacman show and so
we get emails I'm not looking at every
email directly but I'll be notified when
certain concerning things come up and
we've had everything from people who
said they were suicidal
and we were fortunately able to get
medical services involved and to help
them and we later heard from these
people it I really appreciate that
actually that that you know
that my emails just didn't go nowhere
that somebody's monitoring this stuff
even if it's not me we all sorts of
different situations
there are about
10 or so instances where
people were writing to to me they you
know they were writing to me as far as
that they knew at least with what are
called in the mental health field ideas
of reference which
is sort of like when people watch the
show and I'm just speaking to the entire
audience and people start to believe
that I'm sending them a message
specifically and this is sometimes
called ideas of reference and the way it
usually goes is we will get emails from
folks
who will say something along the lines
of I was able to understand based on the
way David's eyes looked while he was
saying something that he was signaling
me there was one which was really sad
which was someone thought that I was
blinking messages in Morse code to them
totally unrelated to the subject matter
about which I was speaking okay
that's that's like a really really sad
thing
and oftentimes these emails will be
completely intermixed with completely
wacky political ideas and I understand
that it can be difficult to draw the
line between where we just have a
political idea and where we go over into
some kind of mental illness and and
again without diagnosing any particular
person with any particular condition
we can have a disagreement about what
the tax rate should be and we would like
mostly say that these are these are sane
conversations and we could be right or
wrong about what's the best tax rate for
this that or the other that would be
very clearly on one side of the spectrum
very clearly on the other side of the
spectrum would be like David you're
you're blinking a message in Morse code
to me okay but then you start to get
into stuff like Flat Earth and we've
talked to experts about conspiracy
theories and these sorts of things where
Flat Earth yeah it's it's an idea that's
sort of like about the nature of our
world but it it is it's so widely
demonstrated that it's wrong that it can
start to kind of eek into some and then
we go into some of the vaccine stuff
well this is all a plot by the Deep
state to
um inject some kind of dormant bio
weapon and then in 2029 Bill Gates will
flip a switch and all of the vaccine
that's been injected into people will
turn them into zombies geez that that
starts to be closer to David's blinking
messages in Morse code to me I don't
know where the line is but one of the
real problems and challenges we have
right now
is that too much stuff that is at best
gray area and at worst outright paranoid
delusions has become acceptable
political discussion among the American
right wing at this point in time
I don't know how we fix it this isn't
about being anti-religious this isn't
about any it's about being anti-insanity
and we have to stop the normalization of
this stuff and Mary Beth saying the
satanic temples grabbing children at
after school
it's pretty gray if not on the far end
of that Spectrum to me let me know what
you think